most bars across clark county have been
closed for a month
it's part of the state's effort to slow
the coronavirus but it's also affecting
a lot of those jobless claims
however those bars could reopen tonight
if
a new coronavirus task force allows the
governor's mandate to expire
hector mejia is live this morning from
the downtown arts district with details
on this hector good morning
good morning john and right now you
cannot walk into a bar that does not
sell
food that is the case here in the arts
district where as you can see right
behind me they've gotten creative with
the signs that are boarding up the
storefronts and the bars well today
the new task force can decide one of two
things one
to either allow the governor's mandate
to expire
and reopen or extend the mandate and
keep the places closed
so let's rewind things a little bit
there's been a lot going on it's been
about a month since governor steve
sislak ordered
most bars to close a second time first
back in march at the start of the
pandemic
and then in july when cases were
skyrocketing there have been lawsuits
most recently a judge in nevada declined
to lift the closure
so now it's up to a new task force to
decide after governor says lot gave them
the authority to reopen safely
so that means with a decision going down
today if bars are allowed to open back
up at midnight
hundreds of business owners will only
have as little as a 12
hours notice to reopen if they wish but
with covid 19 safety regulations
meanwhile casinos across the state have
been allowed to reopen
and that is the reason why a lot of
these business owners across the state
have been saying
that they are being treated unfairly
reporting live from the arts district
hector mejia
8 news now